lady in red again tonight you look
insane thank you well I am I'm upcycling
this dress I wore this dress for the
first time to Vanity Fair in 2004 we
very rarely get a dress gifted to us
Badgley Mischka made this dress for me
back then I I was in Seabiscuit which
was a big Oscar nominee and they gave it
to me and I recently moved and found it
in the back of the closet and it still
fits
so yeah I'm I'm rad on the carpet
tonight very excited to be wearing a
dress recycling a dress from 16 years
ago this is amazing though because this
seems like the theme of fashion on the
red carpet this year during award season
because Jennifer Aniston at the SAG
Awards wore a dress just like I just had
this in my closet
okay can I come over well I think we all
we all know we know so much now about
the impact that fashions having globally
on the climate and it just feels
wasteful and silly and I I like being
able to sort of call out the culture
that shames anybody for wearing
something twice like it's a pretty hot
number why not wear it again all right
so at the Oscars we have I've prepared
all my questions based off best pictures
so choose one it's gonna be based off a
movie tell us the movie the movie is
marriage story what is your best tip to
getting over a broken heart
girls trip to Vegas
[Laughter]
[Music]
you